ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show
vacation is over kids you're going back
to school
says meatball new york schools can
reopen
cuomo says in contrast with much of
us we all know governor cuomo i
affectionately
call him meatball and we know his
brother
chris uh fredo cuomo corleone
who was offended at the name fredo he
thought it was a slur against the
italian american so now we call him
chris
uh uh fredo cuomo corleone and uh
we remember and we forgive him for his
lie that he had coronavirus and beat it
by
chest exercises remember that when chris
cuomo had coronavirus and beat it by
going like this
that's how he beat it so we apparently
shut down the economy
for something that you can beat by just
stretching your chest
in the living room of your home so we
forgive him for his lie
okay like uh like we would do we would
say
what's that line in the godfather uh
which one
uh i don't know he's disappointed in the
kid
is that the godfather i don't know what
you're talking about where he's like
uh i don't know he doesn't he look at
fredo and he was fredo
you you disappoint me or something
what's that famous line
i know it was you fredo that was that
was you know
oh yeah yeah here it is i know it was
you fredo
here you go up there you broke my heart
you broke my arm you broke my heart you
broke my heart when you're lying about
having carotid virus and that you beat
it by doing
chest exercises but we forgave you your
family that's fine
um uh meatball has decided that the kids
are going back to school
and cases in new york are very low and
people are just going to get back to the
business
uh of you know uh bringing the kids into
new york city schools
and um you know not educating them but
so we're happy about that
and the teachers are a lot of the
teachers are not happy
a lot of the teachers are upset um
um but let's be very honest here and i
get flack for this a lot but
i don't shy away from controversial
opinions let's be very honest
have you ever and some of the people
listening
are are gonna not like this have you
ever met a teacher
that wasn't just a little bit of
a self-important [__] i'm speaking of
the female teachers the male teachers we
all know are just pedophiles
many of them very agreeable though and
friendly i mean they have to be they're
you know they [__] the kids
but i mean female teachers many
times are self-important
for lack of a better word see you next
tuesdays
it's just what they are they spend their
entire lives with
children they talk to you like you were
a child
teaching is not the job it was when my
grandmother did it when you didn't get
paid to do it
and it was you had a genuine uh passion
for
teaching children now it is a job
that a lot of people take because it
pays very well in a lot of suburban
areas and also they get the two prime
months of the year off
so i i've likened them
to summer enthusiasts that's what i call
a lot of teachers
summer enthusiasts okay they show up at
7 30 in the morning they hand out some
folders you're out by 2 30 every day oh
no they don't
they don't leave at 2 30. they they stay
for chefs
club great
great okay now not all teachers are bad
okay not all teachers are bad
but if we're gonna broad brush tops
if we're gonna paint with a broad brush
let's
paint you know what i mean and a lot of
teachers
these social interactions you have with
them you dread them they start
explaining
things to you like you need to explain
[__] i'm not nine
i know what the supreme court is pipe
down okay
teaching's the most important job in the
world it is not the most important job
in the world
the the the america is so behind
in every educational standard and all we
do
is praise teachers the statistics are
much
worse for teachers than for cops
much worse yes or yes
where is american reading and math
let's find it out right now
if cops were shooting as many people as
teachers were failing
it would be a cause to abolish them
and this is not all teachers and i don't
want people that are teachers to get
angry with me
i want you to grow up and take a little
criticism okay from a comedian
someone who really knows the ins and
outs
i have a value in society unlike you
showing up to a [__] let's try to
find where we are in
math and reading this is from october
2019. okay math and reading scores
for fourth and eighth graders in the
united states dropped
and the decrease in reading achievement
has government researchers particularly
concerned
over the past decade there has been no
progress
in either mathematic or reading
performance and the lowest performing
students are doing
worse okay
that's the reality
i i don't know how to i mean find find
the statistics i know it's tough
but try to find them because i it's
really an important point that i'm
making here
if we're going to say abolish cops why
not abolish teachers
i'm dead serious here let's abolish
teachers
if you think people can walk around
society and police themselves
kids can teach themselves let's have a
school with no teachers
okay no new toyota camry's pulling up
they get out with their latte
i will get so much hate for this and i
don't care
because i've had it i know a lot of
teachers my aunt is a teacher i respect
her
my grandmother is a teacher and i
respect her i i'm this is not going at
all teachers but we all know
there's a lot of bad teachers and the
good teachers stay silent about it
the good teachers stay silent about the
bad ones
i went to a catholic school we had
teachers that used to make out with the
kids in the hallway
and those were the good teachers
those are the ones who stayed after
class and ran clubs and
cared they helped you fill out your
college application sure they goosed you
sure every now and then they they wanted
your phone number and they wanted to
take you on a date
after school but that's nice we did we
had a teacher
who was a theater teacher who just was
like making out with a girl in the
hallway
holy trinity diocesan hicksville if you
know you know
i'm not trying to get sued
i have a friend whose wife's a teacher i
mean it's like i mean they're just they
just
show up and they just tell you
they talk to you like you're a child and
i'm just saying
so the problem is a lot of them are
going to be upset they feel like they're
being put in an unnecessary risk
and maybe some of them are but
if meatball wants the kids to go back to
school the kids are going to go back to
school
that's what's going to happen and as a
teacher
you want to educate the kids and you're
passionate about it
you're going to have to take a little
bit of a chance and i
i don't say that lightly oh
tim you get to work alone you don't have
to be around anybody
yes i do yes i do
okay i'm sorry that i chose the
profession i chose
i went 10 years without making a dollar
i worked on a tour bus
i tried to sell photocopiers over the
phone you went to a school
you got a degree you got an education
you have all the financial security
pretty much that you can ask for
not always but a lot of the times
especially these teachers that teach in
the burbs
and you know okay world's best education
systems
they're saying that we're number two
that's not true all of them are finding
are saying we're number one or two this
is that's not gonna be right
this is the teachers are running this
this is not true this feels all fake
everything i click on says everything
the kid the kids can't read out there
the kids are on they're they take all
these pills they're black-eyed nihilists
the kids
we we did the video with the kids yeah
and that little kid oliver in there he's
a black-eyed nihilist
he literally believes in nothing to
children they think nothing matters and
they're right
u.s we're gonna have to get back to you
with these [__] statistics but like
our fans will go and find them if we're
125 on a list of 197 countries in terms
of literacy how do we have the best
education system
you can't get the right answers here
anymore
nobody's giving you the right answers
we're not the best education system in
the country
i mean that's crazy it's crazy we're not
most of these teachers don't even know
the three branches of government
go ask a teacher what the three branches
of government are in a public school
they're gonna say the fire department as
one of them
okay i found one that this is usually
where we are yeah we're 20th we're 20th
behind
finland japan south korea denmark russia
norway united kingdom israel sweden hong
kong netherlands belgium
germany china singapore portugal hungary
estonia france
and then the united states of america
so the answer is put the kids back in
school trim the fat
that's the reality some of the teachers
aren't going to make it i feel bad about
that the world is not perfect
we could all die tomorrow i could die
tomorrow and then all you'd be left with
is these brilliant archives of a
misunderstood genius okay
but but meatball has spoken
and he said that there is no economy
without the kids in schools
there is no economy without the children
going back to school
so that their parents can can stop
pretending to care about them
one of the biggest impediments to
putting the economy back together
is kids are running around the streets
right now filming tick tocks and taking
drugs
and what needs to happen is they need to
go back into school
where they could be in a social
environment and have teachers
watch them and attempt to educate them
okay that's what we need so that their
parents can go back
to work that's what needs to happen
we're not able to do anything unless the
kids are in school
so yeah a lot of teachers are gonna come
down on me go you don't know what a hard
job it is
you don't know how tough it is yeah
you're right i don't
you're right i doubt okay
i will t i've all i will teach
but it's got to be what i want i'm not
going to teach the common core
curriculum
that meatball and his brother want i
will teach
i will teach different classes what
about a class called 911 a closer look
with mr dylan
i'll do it okay
but i'm not going to teach this uh
horseshoe here's a scarlet letter read
the scarlet letter
what hey rita tales of fourth grade
nothing
no we're not doing that
we will spend the semester investigating
the attacks of 9 11.
and you'll go home every day and tell
your parents what you've learned
the kids that i don't know how the paul
brothers did in school but they're doing
fine
jake paul is doing fine he's got an
arsenal
fbi removes firearms from jake paul's
mansion in probe of shopping mall riot
i commend him i go the other way i say
get more guns jake
get a nuke get some chemical weapons
start experimenting manipulating bat
coronaviruses
that seems to have worked i say go big
la's gonna fall all my friends like
whitney cummings and joe rogan they're
gonna be out of here
i need to ingratiate myself with these
people because they're gonna have a
compound and an arsenal
don't you need someone to make you laugh
jake you got a harem of women you got
enough people to film you
but you're gonna need a jester a court
jester let me walk around
your calabasas mansion and be a goofball
you can throw things at me break eggs on
my head
and when the city falls i will be behind
the walls
with you and the rpgs that you own
yes or yes please please god help me
i can't be here when the city crumbles
the only people that are going to be
able to defend themselves when the end
comes or youtubers and tick tockers
charlie dimiglio's gonna have a house
with a moat with alligators in it
if you get too close they're gonna burn
you alive they're gonna torch you
so i just need to get in with these
people for christ
god what's wrong
he made one mistake he left a rifle by
the hot tub
and some rat some rat informed on him no
good
i will enforce loyalty i will be the
jester i will
i will make you laugh i just want to
know that when the end
comes i will be behind the gates behind
the walls
and i will be protected by your
considerable arsenal and i think we
should start expanding quite frankly
i don't think we should only have guns i
think we should experiment
with a small bioweapons lab on the
property you have the space
you have the spaces calabasas you have
the space let's do a small bio weapons
lab
why not i hope he has that i hope he has
a hydrogen bomb
he deserves it because he didn't listen
to teachers who told him to read his
books
and not go on youtube
he went on the internet he said i want
to live in a big house with a lot of
guns
and i want to rap if i want and do i rap
it doesn't matter anyway
does anyone even do anything anymore
nothing matters
our president was a game show host you
can be whatever you want to be now you
can be versatile
all these tick-tock girls just have
these auto-tuned songs and the whole
song is like
i'm sad i get sad other people get tat
where's that i'm sad you're sad
doesn't matter they can't [__] sing
can you do an auto-tune
on my voice uh in post i can yeah if you
want to sing right now
millions of dollars they're sad all the
time but it doesn't matter
so i commend him and i want to join
forces with him
in his what i imagine the fbi is calling
it loosely
a loosely formed militia i don't know
what what even happened to this guy what
do you have a bunch of guns
they took the guns yeah they just
checked his guns yeah
he needs guns yeah he does the guy needs
guns he's done well
i'm just offering my services here as
somebody that could commit to the
operation
yeah i like that i like this this is
when he got in trouble for the mall
thing he goes
i'm above that he said i don't need to
vandalize i don't need to loot i know
it's not the way forward
again that's like a better position than
joe biden
why does jake paul have a better
position why can't joe biden say that
why why can't joe biden say yeah uh
chaos and violence is not the way far
why is jake paul
making more sense than joe biden
can joe biden say that can joe biden
come out and say anything publicly
is he alive do you want to lose again
i i just don't understand trump's going
to win again
with a pandemic and an economic crash
he's going to win again these polls are
not right
i watched that interview where everybody
was like trump is
he looks so bad because he does get
crazy with the papers he starts flinging
these papers around and look at this
chart and look at that chart
papers are never a good idea in an
interview it's never a good idea to be
like and look at the
diagram that nobody wins nobody wins i
was a juror on a murder trial and as
soon as
the lawyers brought out the diagrams
everything we all just went to sleep
it's true okay we didn't even pay
attention it's like use your words and
if you can't
stop like look at this photo this and
the blood splattering and all that no
one cares
so it's never a good idea to use that
what makes sense
okay is to uh
just speak and say what those things say
but when i watched the interview i was
actually pleasantly surprised
uh with trump i thought he was composed
i thought he was eloquent
i thought he made some bad points and
some good ones but i didn't see anything
i mean it was like they're trying to win
an election on twitter they're going to
lose it in real life you have a british
guy
get an american you have a british guy
it most people have like a weird
reaction to a british god be like oh yes
well
i don't think he's lost that actually
well actually mr president how do i
think
it nobody wants that get an american
reporter
who can can try to do a takedown of this
guy because you have they got their own
problems in britain
okay meghan markle and that idiot are
here now
they live in l.a so
we don't need somebody from outside of
our country critiquing
our country okay and i know he's a
citizen or whatever he's white
so i can say whatever i want in terms of
him being an outsider
he's got a british accent if he was that
american he would he would not speak
you know i don't even know if he's a
citizen or what he is but
my point is that there's a visceral
reaction to that also trump made a lot
of good points about portland
not so much i don't like the vans
picking up the people i'm not for that i
think it's a bad idea
but in explaining that divorcing myself
from any emotion
in explaining that he did a good job
explaining that
i don't think he's necessarily right but
he did a good job
and i just think again you know you're
looking at
and the mail-in voting thing is like
what are we not going to know the the
winner of the election on the night of
the election
it seems that way yeah we're going to
have a month or two of not knowing i
mean
are we insane that was fun in 2000
because we all didn't hate each other
yet
so it was really fun like late night
hosts were funny snl was doing some of
their best work
we're all making fun of catherine harris
the secretary of state of florida
i mean it was goofy people like we don't
need a president no one cared it was 2
000. things were good there was no 911
nobody knew what the taliban was
everybody was fine social media hadn't
taken over our lives
we weren't inundated with every new
development i mean it was 24-hour cable
news but there was a
healthy dose of of detachment there were
people that were mad about
it and people that were invested in it
but it was nowhere near
what a month of not knowing that the
outcome of this election will be
not knowing the outcome of this election
will be fatal
probably for the country we really need
to know
so the only way to have this election is
hope to god
a second wave does not hit i hope to god
a second wave does not hit in the fall
because a second wave comes in the fall
and people are unable to vote and they
are sending in mail-in ballots
and the legitimacy of those is going to
be challenged it's going to be a close
election both sides are not going to
accept it
the winner is going to be seen as
illegitimate there's gonna be riots and
chaos and protests and problems and this
and that the economy's not
you know it's gonna be the perfect
[__] storm
for this country so i'm hoping and
trump made a few points about that
and you know and i think trump is
obviously the advantage there because
his voters are crazy
a little bit some of them not all of
them but
you know democrats their voters probably
have a higher incidence of not going to
the polls
but you got to go vote wear the mask and
vote
that's what you got to do i mean i think
we just have to have an election
we have to have an election where the
mass can vote
if you can protest if you can go out if
you can gather
if we can open schools as meatball said
then we can have a real election where
you wear a mask and you sanitize your
hands and you press a button i believe
that
i don't know you know trump goes with
universal mail in voting not absentee
voting which is good 2020 will be the
most inaccurate and fraudulent election
history do not allow this by the way
take this issue away from him
by having a regular election hopefully
if we can unless corona is exploding and
it's crazy
uh you know which point i mean i guess
you still have to have one i mean i
don't know
that you can do a mail-in election that
anyone is going to see is valid
to be honest because the first time
we've had an all mail in election
and if it's very close it's just going
to be a problem this is not the climate
to start like
trying new things let's vote by text
like this is not the time you got to
probably do it the old-fashioned way
so that people can feel comfortable in
the result i don't know
but i'm just wondering about that i'm
not certain
that it's susceptible to the type of
fraud he thinks it is but i'm sure it is
susceptible to a certain level of fraud
you know i don't know about that
folks this is time to start thinking
about making extra money we all know
that we all know that we can feel it the
worst
is not here yet it's coming it's coming
and
what you can do to really insulate
yourself from some of the horrors that
are heading your way is to maybe start a
little online business
start shipping those little trinkets
that horseshit that you've collected
your entire life maybe it's been handed
down to you from your mother your father
your grandmother grandmother who knows
great aunt who cares
but you know it's time to get it out of
your house also maybe it's time to start
painting and selling your paintings i
mean making little crafts i don't know
what you're gonna do
but if you're starting an e-commerce
business one of the most important
things to do is check out shipstation
okay as you adapt to the changing world
we're all going to be buying more stuff
online
and if you're an e-commerce seller and
you're ready to meet the demands
are you of our new delivery culture be
ready
chip station is essential when you're
selling online
when you're getting a lot of orders
trying to get them out fast it can be
tough
how do you keep track of who gets what
which ship and carrier should you use
are you getting the best rates that's
why you need ship station it's the
fastest easiest
most affordable way to manage and ship
your orders just a few clicks and you'll
be managing your orders
printing out labels and getting your
products to happy customers
shipstation makes it easy okay
i mean i i use ship station
because i have a side business which a
lot of people don't know about
i make things out of human hair dolls
and
stuff and i get i get the hair and i
make little dolls out of here
and i i was getting so many orders for
the hair dolls
that it was getting overwhelming and i
wasn't able to keep track of anything
and sometimes i'll take fingernails and
give
the hair dozen faces with nails and
it's nice because a lot of families
can't afford to buy their kids uh
stuffed animals or presents so
you get a hair doll or if you're you're
a dreadlock doll because who are diverse
um and then i make make dolls of hair
and then their faces are made out of
nail clippings
um and then the red lips like red lips i
get like blood
to make like like kissy face lips and
they
it took off i thought people go oh this
is gross we don't want this call the fbi
it didn't happen they went nuts they
love them they love them they love them
they're just they can't stop talking
about them
everybody enjoys it so no matter what
you're selling amazon etsy your own
website shipstation brings all of your
orders
into one simple interface making them
really easy to manage
from any device even your cell phone i'm
on the go somebody in australia orders a
[__]
hair doll with a a blood mouth and
uh you know um eyebrows
you know made out of human nail
i'm able to go oh good i see the order
it goes through it's paired with the
perfect carrier i don't have to think
about it so important for me
so important for me uh to be able to
manage these orders because there's so
many other problems with that business
getting the hair getting the nails
putting it together
uh it's so you know really i'm worried
about that
more so that i'm worried about the
shipping and the organization of it all
you know i'm worried about like
prison and stuff so
it's so tough you know we're coming out
with it
we're going to start using human skin to
make dresses for them and we're so
excited i'm
really excited because i've always been
kind of a crafty person
and i just now during this quarantine i
really haven't had the time to really
kind of put my
i i feel like there's so many people in
america women especially who are maybe
crafty you know who i'm talking about
you know the six women who listen to
this show
all of you are crafty and everything you
do is artistic
and and it should be out there to a
larger audience
and ship station is is amazing okay you
can compare and choose the best shipping
solution for you and your customer
okay nothing is forced on you okay they
even pay big discounts on shipping costs
now any business can access the same
postage discounts
that are usually reserved for large
fortune 500 companies you'll always know
that you're getting the best deal okay
and right now the 10 billion show
listeners can try ship station free for
60 days when you use the promo code
offer code tim dillon t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n
make sure your business is ready to meet
the demands of delivery culture
get started at shipstation.com today and
even though i kid around about this
if you do want to have um
an e-commerce business or an online
business you're a fan of my show
ship station is great you get 60 days
free so if you're starting a business
the most essential period is early on
when you're not turning a profit yet
you're not making the money these are
60 days of using a product or a service
free that is essential that you need
that can organize
all the things you're doing send them
out so whatever kind of business you're
running if it's an e-commerce business
if it involves shipping
it is essential that you check this out
okay you go to shipstation.com
s-h-i-p-s-t-a-t-i-o-n shipstation.com
enter the code tim dillon and you get
two months for free
i'm telling you you're gonna love it
2020 has been the year of things
happening that are completely out of
your control but there is one thing you
can control and that's shaving your bush
manscaped here's the deal with manscaped
you have
pubic hair it gets too much you use this
it's great it's better than the norelco
body groom there's not a ton of razors
on the market that do this job
it's very sensitive you don't bleed out
you don't lose your dick you know unless
you want to and i support your choice
um but the reality is this is a perfect
perfect situation
for people that want to trim themselves
up
make sure that their uh junk is
you know good you know your penis looks
bigger when you get rid of all the hair
the lawnmower 3.0 is a waterproof it
comes with an led light so you can
led light so you can manscape in the
shower in the dark or in a dark
shower whatever floats your boat they
just released the shears 2.0 nail kit
which is a perfect add-on to their
lawnmower 3.0 trimmer
so i just pick my nails like i don't
even file them or
i just kind of pick them each i'll go
like this what do you do i just rip them
off
i rip them off with anxiety and terror
the lawnmower 3.0 is uh the way to go it
is really good do you use the lawnmower
3.0
i do yeah isn't it great it is good i
actually use it good it works
you know you don't even have to pay
attention to it you just kind of
just yeah just that and you can just do
it easily and
it's nice you know you know that's the
way it is
they also have the crop reviver a testy
toner
that's like having cologne that is
designed for your balls
okay so if you want your balls to smell
like cologne some people do other people
don't
you can you have that but the main thing
here is the lawnmower 3.0
if you like this show if you appreciate
what we do here
and you have genitalia that you want to
keep in working order
listeners of the show will get 20 off
and free shipping with the code tim d
at manscape.com that's code tim d at
manscape.com 20
off free shipping it's time to grab 2020
by the horns
by shaving that front trunk who writes
this
you know jesus but really it's great
it's important you need it
bushes are really out people want
you know they just want it to be more
reined in
thank you you know i just moved to the
desert we used to get
my roommate wanted us to get her mail we
used to put her mail
in the thing and when she got it uh we
would go oh good
you know like i didn't even think she'd
ever get it you know
was it my job to send her her mail but
we did it we did it nicely yes you know
what i mean we didn't do anything wrong
you know we had a little issue with the
roommate you know we had a little
issue there and i mean it's not uh you
know i
i i talk about my life on the show and i
i like this young woman and i feel
bad about what happened but me and you
were accused wrongly of
destroying an apartment with leftovers
food uh it was said that they were
maggots
and they were thinking uh none of this
is the case it's not it's not true this
is untrue
it's untrue and we don't like it it's
not nice when people say things like
that when i've been very nice to those
people it's very unknown it's very not
nice
you know what i mean and if peop you
know people may be having experiences
that aren't based in reality
because of drinking and substances and
that's that is i was a drug addict for
many years i get it
and i would just say that reality you
need to operate from reality
you cannot operate from a place of
you know you cannot blame me for bugs in
the apartment if you're feeling the
sensation of bugs on your skin
because that is not something in reality
that is uh
a symptom of crack cocaine and again
and that's it's neither here nor there
she's not really a public person it
doesn't matter
obviously i never said her name um but i
just feel
that i i just don't like i don't like
the lying
i don't like lying just be
nice everybody's nice here we're all
nice all we try to do is help all i try
to do is do work
uh to bring people happiness and joy and
i just don't understand why
i don't understand why that's not
appreciated more
and that it's denigrated and that you're
attacked you're texted and you're
attacked
i was attacked yes you were attacked and
i left that place clean
through everything on the dumpster you
know what it is
if you're huffing chemicals do you
really know what's going on
and i'm not saying she is but i'm just
saying
if you have blue lips from huffing
chemicals
i don't know i don't know what you're
seeing you might be seeing things
you might be seeing animals climbing the
windows and that's my fault too
i don't know it's not my you know but
i just you know
peace and light love and light that's
all i put out all i put out is goodness
love and light
and that's uh like that real housewife
from new jersey
the woman that i don't know the fbi and
the kokor danielle uh danielle
uh danielle uh
danielle real housewife jersey danielle
danielle
uh oh daniel staub
whose real name is beverly ann merrill
she used to say love and light
and she was involved with all kinds of
crazy people and did all kinds of crazy
things but
that is what i profess to do i just
bring love and light and i try to be
bring positivity and and joy to people i
just want that to kind of be respected
and like
this idea that i would
like i'm some type of animal or some
barnyard creature is just not the case
i mean this is just not the case and i
don't i don't understand why this is
being i mean i scratched her car i
borrowed her car
to go to nobu in malibu uh and
i scratched the front of him and i
paid thousands of dollars to have a new
panel put on the car
correct i got new brake pads for the car
new shocks for the car everything like
that the car is a 10 year old
hatchback of a car it's what
i gave you know i i was gonna say hey
take the money for the car instead
take the money for the car and just
drive it with a scratch
i'll give you the two grand that it
would cost to fix the car
you take that two grand you know and go
buy heroin
now
but i fixed the car and then she text me
because you destroyed the car
i don't know i just i got an event
they're going to talk about things here
i wouldn't
what am i going to do not speak of the
things that haunt me
that wake me up at night i'm a good
person i just do the right things
all i do is help do the right things
here then i'm i'm attacked i
i [__] the car up i destroyed the
apartment i destroyed this woman's life
i did none of that i did none of that
i'm getting text all night i'm a
horrible per i've destroyed this
everything i touch turns to [__] this is
horrible to say to a human being i'm a
sensitive boy
i'm a sensitive young man you can't say
those things to me that's
mean what are you ellen degeneres
have some conscience
we had a lovely dinner you threw out all
of the things from la scala
in the dumpster not even into the trash
in there dumpster they went
i don't understand why these attacks not
only on me but on you
on me as well this innocent uh
kid from texas is just a wide-eyed he
just came to l.a
you know and uh he doesn't eat
i know these people i've grown up with
these people
okay i'm not roommates with somebody by
accident
we're both scumbags
i'll be a drug addict till i die i just
don't currently use drugs
but i am a scumbag
this gentleman doesn't deserve that
he grew up he went to like a schoolhouse
you know where it's one house
and then you did and they had a school
marm
and he would go in and i mean this kid
just grew up
i mean the stories he has the life he's
lived
it he just he just deserves a little
respect he can't attack okay
you can attack me because i'm a
dirtbag like
everyone i've ever met is that funny
isn't it funny how dirt bags seem to
find each other but i'm just saying it's
wrong to attack
benjamin
as well i i think that's a little shitty
to do
we didn't go in there i wasn't throwing
chicken parmesan all over the apartment
[Music]
hey
jack's like i was taking shits on the
floor
it's an old apartment you have old rugs
it's musty
you have clothes it's gross it's a
[__]
that's why we live there cause it was a
it's not nice
okay it's a place for an actor to
hang themself that's what the apartment
is
and i'm sorry there was an odor in the
apartment
i'm sorry yes okay febreze at all
so that the next person who lives there
and tries to
kill themself it smells frat i don't
know what to tell you but the text
started rolling and it came to me they
came to benjamin
i'm not spending the whole show on this
but i just feel like
it's a little much it's a little much
the attacks
i'm disappointed to impugn my character
as such
that's all it disappoints me he doesn't
understand
the way people i understand the way
people operate he doesn't even
understand it
through no fault of his own he comes
from vast open expanses big blue skies
he doesn't get it he doesn't get wheeler
dealers
he doesn't understand the different
people in the way that they operate in
this planet
he doesn't get it i get it i've known
him since i was a young child
he's never met someone like meatball
the governor of new york andrew cuomo or
his brother
chris fredo cuomo corleone
it's his real name i'm not being racist
against italians that's his name frisk
uh who didn't have coronavirus never
forget
no you beat it like this no you don't
you didn't have it never forget liar
liar liar
so we're on the other side of that i
wish this woman the best
same i wish everyone the best i'm
saddened
i'm saddened i'm saddened by the lack
of decorum what happened
to people knowing how to communicate
this social media has [__] everything
up
i really believe that do you think that
yeah this social media
i mean this social media has really
[__] everything up it has really
destroyed people's minds
as crack cocaine does this is just
i'm just comparing social media to crack
i'm not they're very similar you get a
hit you want another head head
who is speaking at the democratic
national convention not
aoc they say
this year's virtual time crunch
democratic national convention isn't
making space for many top democrats to
speak
the dnc is set aside just two hours
every night from august 17th through the
20th
for the convention where former
president joe biden will prove he's
alive
joke except the nomination that has led
the biden campaign to make some ruthless
cuts to some of the highest profile
democrats out there
uh though the convention's official
schedule is far from finalized
it goes without saying that the party's
two most popular figures barack obama
and michelle obama will get a big role
even with time limited former president
bill clinton
and 2016 nominee hillary clinton are in
as well
the clintons are in
why not have just lane maxwell speak
at the convention if we're going to have
the clintons there
credible accusation of him being on
epstein's island they're going to roll
him out
at the convention have barack
have michelle have meatball done
meatball michelle barack
biden over not aoc
not ilhan omar easy
stay in the main centrist lane
you're not gonna give anyone health care
anyway you might as well win the
election
maybe then you do something good you
cannot have bill clinton out there the
man
looks like he died years ago and he did
die years ago
so he died when he could stop sticking
his dick in whatever he wants
in a hard condition he had to go vegan
aoc reportedly does not have a slot yet
nor do any of her fellow progressive
political newcomers
but the party has reportedly made room
for ohio governor john kasich a
republican who ran against president
trump in 2016
he'll speak on the same night as bernie
sanders in a demonstration of unity
so john kasich has got well you know
bernie's people love that they love when
you know
someone else and bernie get together
that you know might have
you know might not be traditionally a
you know a guy that you'd think would
align with bernie they
they handled that very well i think i
remember bernie went on a podcast
with a guy that maybe wouldn't
traditionally be a bernie supporter but
really liked bernie's platform
and i seem to remember the left handling
that very well
not to leave the right out of criticism
the other day i was out in the desert
and there was a uh trump rally and now
it's
like it's just these rich middle-aged
women here's what it is man it just
gives them something to do yeah
it gives them something to do it's just
these rich middle-aged women in
hatchback
uh mercedes top-down pink trump flags
women for trump
they pull into some parking lot they're
all yelling you're all trying to get
people to honk
as they drive behind it's like well what
is the point here
what exactly are we doing like who cares
why are
can you just enjoy your [__] top-down
mercedes on a nice day and drive
listen to some music put on a little
david bowie and just
go you got to have a woman for trump
sign
flags they have flags in the car put it
on my instagram
and then they pulled over and they'll
start you know beeping
no masks by the way many of them were
mask-less yeah this is on my instagram
on the story it should still be there no
no it's over 24 hours
if you didn't see it it's over
24 hours to get the good stuff on
instagram and then that is
it but there's something funny
to me about like like
they call them like pool and patio types
like
upper middle class or even potentially
wealthy people
that are like treating politics like
it's like
you know like some like pep rally it's
like still school spirit night
because they have nothing to do they're
unaffected by anything so they're just
trying to
find something in their life to get into
so they listen to like sean hannity
every day and they're like
you see them on facebook all fighting
with each other trying to score points
like
you know they're so satisfied when they
write like a long comment they're like
now you go i'll raise you that and so
much of this just comes out of boredom
how much of this truly is boredom
ray kump always says people don't have
hobbies anymore
nobody's like trying to learn how to
paint nobody's doing any woodworking
nobody's putting together a table
they're just looking for something to
lose themselves in
some social [__] situation
it's just their identity i mean these
women women for like the woman was like
like the woman who's driving the car me
devin and i are in the car and
we look at her and she's like and we
just smiled and
she was like we're smiling but i wanted
to you know drive by them and
i think it's funny whenever you see no
matter what
group they are but especially if they're
republican but if they're really like
frothing at the mouth and they're happy
it's always funny to just take it a step
further let's see how far
they'll go see how far they'll go he's
just a little funny so i wanted to drive
by and be like
yeah white power just to see
like what these like
upper middle class desert housewives
would do
like you know if i just drove by and i
was like yeah yeah
trump trump highlander
i mean they've gone along with it i
don't know how bad are things getting
you know
with a bunch of like housewives just
start [__] making nazi salutes
the middle of the street how bad is it
out there
sometimes i want to know
you know just a hot climate for race
i read an article the other day about
cultural appropriation i can't
understand cultural appropriation i
don't understand
um all cultures add to each other i mean
some of it obviously
some of it uh obviously is
um yeah the quite how viral tic tac
video is laying bare cultural
appropriation through slang
see i don't even know what this is but i
mean again
could there be any less important issue
than cultural appropriation i mean
obviously within reason
if you're a white person you should
don't walk around into sheiki
like nancy pelosi or whatever don't
you know you don't need dreadlocks if
you're a white perk you know
there's something weird about white
millennial women opening up a fried
chicken restaurant
but it should be allowed you shouldn't
go crazy like in portland where it was
like people making burritos and they
weren't mexican so
like they had to close their stand down
should be within reason
but the reason this impacts me is
because i was an actor as
a kid i was in theater it's a man of the
theater and i
i was a singer as a child and i sang and
i had a beautiful voice
and then after many many years of hard
living and cigarettes
i really can only sing one song
i can only sing one song and what's
unfortunate
about this song is that it is
it's a beautiful song it's one of my
favorites so it's a powerful song
but it is traditionally sung by a black
person
and it is from a song it's from a show
called showboat
and the words of the song correspond to
that person's experience now i would
have i would never ask
to play the role and sing the song in a
play
but if i wanted to sing it socially
or at karaoke one night
um i don't know why i shouldn't be
allowed to sing it because
i've smoked so many cigarettes and i've
had a lot of dairy and i've treated my
voice bad
um i just don't understand why i can't
go to like a los angeles karaoke
and and go old man
river that old man
river he don't say and
you have to do a little bit of like the
black scent it's i'm not even i don't
even want to do it
it's like i i'm not mad
if a black person was singing like an
irish song i think it's beautiful
if if if erica badu sang danny boy
i would tears down my face
and if she jazzed it up danny bye
danny by the pipes are calling how great
would that be why am i upset by that
why am i upset by
erica badou singing danny boy i'm not
so why can't i because i can hit the
notes
it dawn plantators
see i can go down there low
and i can stay down there and it's nice
he old man river
he just keeps rolling
[Music]
like why why is that offensive
i understand i'm not saying that i'm
like
i'm not like piggybacking off the
experience of slavery the original sin
of america i get it's horrible
my question is i don't want to play the
role
if i were to sing old man river
at karaoke
would that be okay get a little
drunk and get thrown in
jail like that
now it's it's not my experience as a
white
suburban guy but i have a very
deep voice it is not my choice
i would like to sing at a higher pitch
but i can't
and i think this becomes a problem so a
cultural appropriation
you know within reason has never
bothered me because i
really can only sing old man river
impressively that's the only song that i
can sing
and i don't care if somebody else wants
to sing another song how cool would that
be
can't we get mature as a society and get
past all this [__]
erica badu comes on
sings danny boy makes
irish people cool i don't care that
erica badu is not some drunk
standing on a hill or whoever the [__]
is supposed to be singing danny boy
whatever experience she's you know
trying to
piggyback you know how great would it be
oh this is interesting is it cultural
appropriation when a black woman does an
irish chance they're probably going to
say no
because in the whole hierarchy because
black people have faced more oppression
than
irish people they're allowed but i think
that's a bad way
to order society it creates all this
unnecessary
uh you know consternation and it's very
confusing
and it creates resentment and i don't
think you need to do that i think
what you should do is have everybody
experience
each other's cultures add to each
other's cultures fusion
food is great because maybe you take
french you know les panas which is a
great restaurant it doesn't exist
anymore but it was in new york city
it was in the saint regis hotel none of
you literally have ever been
and the chevrolet got him great cuns
coons cons let's call him cuns for this
[__] point of the show
and he used classical french
techniques and asian flavors
so he would use things like lemongrass
and things like that and then used
classical and it was like the top
restaurant in the city
beautiful i i never went i never went to
les paul and i always wanted to go
and my parents never took me to le
espana so i became a gay cocaine addict
and gave them no children
i'm going to see them in new york before
they will both i have covered
in the second wave and i promise that
they will both dive covered in the
second wave
because i'm spending money on a trip
they will both die i've covered
um but why why would we not do that why
would we not
take a technique from a country and an
ingredient from a cup why would we not
marry them together
now like i get we all cringe
when we see like uh
young young white people like
rapping or something like we all kind of
like
is she a young white girl be like yo yo
like we all go
yeah no we all feel a certain way we
feel a certain way but i
i tell you this i'll tell you this you
would not feel that way if you saw
saw me sing old man river you would not
feel that because you would look at me
and understand immediately that i know
the pain not all of the pain
but i i've had pain and i have uh
uh i can express myself in a way that is
that i do
that i honor the song and i honor the
material
you know when a white girl is just like
that's not it
but when i get up there and i go spend a
little money
and you wind up in oh and you
land in jail
when i hit that jail when i hit that
jail
when i hit it all your doubts
fly away fly away i don't want to do it
on stage i don't want to do it in film
i'm saying can i for karaoke
sing old man river and bring
everybody down to the realities of
racial injustice
because at karaoke everybody's like just
singing journey
and all this horse [__] and i want to
get in there and sing something
that makes an impact sadly the only
thing i can sing is a very low
song these are questions these are
genuine questions i'm not
i'm not trying to you know
should i have sang that to my roommate
my ex roommate i like her she's a funny
woman
you know it's just it's unfortunate it's
sad
it's sad
wouldn't it be funny if you didn't tell
me and you went back the next day and
just destroyed the apartment with food
and that's what she's talking about
i just you know i just don't understand
i understand that uh you know
people often have a different view of
the same set of circumstances
this happens all the time when people
are witnesses to a murder
one person sees one thing another person
sees another thing and they're looking
at the same thing
eyewitness testimonies really a lot of
times is kind of unreliable sometimes it
is reliable
um but a lot of times it isn't
and it's not because people are lying
it's because people are having different
experiences
and i think that we we should recognize
that
and we should appreciate that i'm not
i'm not saying that i feel like i got me
too but it was about leftover food
that's what i feel like i feel like i
was getting attacked
okay by a woman
saying things that were not true but the
accusations were not sexual assault
sexual misconduct they were
you left out leftovers and there are
maggots
that to me is a me too
it is an assault i need to correct a
record
i need to say i need to categorically
deny that i did it
and i may need to hire a lawyer and sue
her
i will not stay i can't stay silent and
i won't stay silent
about the accusation that i left out
food
and that there were maggots and flies
this is untrue untrue this is untrue
summer's here it's crazy hot outside we
all know you want to drink more water
but by the time you feel thirsty it's
too late that's very important you're
already hydrated you can't
you're already dehydrated you cannot
focus and you feel tired it's critical
right how much water should you drink
each day 10 cups a gallon the good news
is it doesn't have to be so complicated
that's why i start my day with hydrant
hydrant helps you hydrate faster okay
it's created refreshing electrolyte
powder that you mix directly into water
to more efficiently and effectively
hydrate your body it's not caffeine
you know there's a tiny bit of maybe
sugar but it's natural it's not any of
this [__] there's no added
sugars and additives it's not chemical
there's no caffeine
you know i'm telling you it's backed by
research the formula
was developed by an oxford scientist
it's also loved by pro athletes
top performers celebrity and thousands
of five star reviews the reason that
you're not a pro athlete or a celebrity
quite frankly is you're not drinking
hydrant these people do things you don't
even understand
they replace their blood they get blood
plasma replacement and everything
they're just at the top of their
working condition they're at the top of
their physical game physical and mental
you know
so just empty the package of this [__]
in the water and stir it around and
drink it and
you too you have a fighting chance of
being a celebrity or a professional
athlete or somebody a
big wall street tycoon because that's
what you need
you need a package of this powder you
stir it in the water it is good it's
better
get off the coffee get off the caffeine
get off the sugar
i mean it's it's really the way it is
you have to change what you're doing you
will have
it really tastes incredible and it works
you think clearer
you're sharp you're on the ball you're
focused you're fast just energy it's
happening you're moving you're grooving
you're shaking you're going you
you don't care what's happening traffic
doesn't bother you because you sit there
start doing math problems like a
beautiful mind you lose your
you know all your depression and anxiety
you free it's like the drug from
limitless you take a little of this
powder
you stir in water you walk into your
office take your dick out and tell your
boss go hey suck it
doesn't matter if it's big you'll be
proud of it you walk in he won't be
disgusted by it
okay he'll just start slobbing on your
dick slobbing it
back and forth working the shaft sucking
the balls
licking the taint maybe he'll even go
into the back door
push your [__] open with his tongue
start eating you out
these are important things and then
he'll say [__] it this company is now
yours you have the company now you own
the company
and you sell it to a chinese company
because you say [__] it [__] america i'm
going where the money is
you no longer have loyalty to your
country of loyalty to an overall
financial architecture
that allows you to maximize profits
everywhere and you realize this
you key into this two days ago you were
schmuck with a middle management office
job
no care but you bought this powdered
[__] and you stirred it in the [__]
water
you [__] your boss in his face and
then you sold his company to china
okay and the only reason you don't want
to [__] his wife is you're gonna [__] a
model
that's right you start hanging out with
elon musk and people like richard
branson you start talking about
terraforming leaving the [__] planet
that's what you're gonna [__] do
then all of a sudden you're going
leaving the planet you're in a [__]
spaceship looking down at those schmucks
on earth starting their day at dunkin
[__]
donuts why because you went to drink
hydrant dot com
slash tim and enter the promo code tim
for 25 off your first order that is
drink hydrant.com
tim and entered promo code tim for 20
25 off your first order that is a
quarter off many of you are so dumb you
don't even realize that
but you're not going to be done for long
you start tricking this hydrate
everything will change you want to be
the president you want to be a major
league baseball player you want to be a
ceo
what do you want to be what do you want
to be you don't want to be sitting in
traffic
eating a donut slurping down some coffee
headed to your dead-end
[__] job you want to be a player a
boss a king
a lion and the way to get there is by
emptying a
bag of powdered [__] that's good
in the water stirring it around and
drinking it
that's the [__] secret not college
not a book not networking not a secret
cult of meets in the woods
not blackmail this is the trick
it's an adult version of tang remember
that crap
that he probably drank where he grew up
that's what you need to do is go to
drinkhydro.com
tim folks the retirement accounts are
good i'm glad you still have them but
get them out of the market get them in
the gold it needs to happen you need to
transition some of your retirement
accounts
into gold i'm telling you it makes sense
the dollar is weakening
i mean they're gonna do the two trillion
dollar bailout we need it they probably
even need more it's going to be a
problem it's an economic house of cards
fiat currency the whole thing
it's a problem you know the money system
you know jekyll island the whole thing
the fed
blah blah blah you know what it is and
it's a goddamn problem out there
you need to really insulate yourself you
know what i mean you ever see gold on
someone's neck immediately you go that's
gold
it's recognizable it's real you can feel
it touch it
bite it they make edible gold sometimes
they put little flakes of it
on chocolate desserts i don't know why
but people like it i don't even know how
it tastes
i can't afford one but here's a reality
birch gold group is here to convert your
roth ira or your 401k partially or fully
whatever you want to do into a precious
metals ira
okay you can still put it in a tax
exempt security that is linked to
precious metals
it is good to diversify the rich
diversified they have money in metal
they have money and money
they have money in stocks they have
money in bonds they're all over the
place what separates you from the rich
that you are not diversified you're the
whims of the market you don't know what
the government's going to do what kind
of money they're going to print what the
fed's going to do
you are at the whims of the market it's
a bad place to be you have no
power they will ship the gold right to
your house or you can put it somewhere
and
to a bank or whatever uh you know
whatever
well what's the word for it when
somebody uh you know uh i don't know but
you could give it to that thing and
they'll
handle it all the time they don't care
it's uh i forget the name but it's a
real thing and
you could park your gold there uh like a
[__]
why do i not it's like uh you know when
you have a will
you have uh what do you have when you
have somebody who's watching over your
trust
they're a uh there's uh there's someone
there that's holding it for you
it's somebody who can help you it's a
trustee maybe that's
it a trustee i don't know enough stop
googling it bring the head back
up you're so [__] slow
um the company i trust with my precious
metal purchases is birch gold group
right now thanks to a little known tax
law you can even move your ira
eligible 401k into an ira backed by
physical gold and silver it's real
it's perfect for those who want to
protect the hard-earned retirement
savings from any more uncertainty and
downturn in stocks
take it out of stocks stocks are about
to crash put it in gold do it now i'm
not even kidding
stocks are about to crash put in a goal
to do it now especially if it's your
retirement it's your only thing
okay contact birch gold group to request
a free kit
on physical precious metals see if
diversifying into gold makes sense for
you this comprehensive 20 page kit
reveals how gold and silver can protect
your savings and how you can legally
move your ira or 401k
out of risky stocks and bonds and into a
precious metals ira to get your no cost
free obligation
text him to 474747 for a limited time
see how you can qualify for ten thousand
dollars in free
precious metals on your purchase text
tim two four seven
four seven four seven and see about
really starting to protect
your retirement you know we're doing
we're doing video now on the patreon for
the rothschilds we had a lot of fun we
were watching the jim baker who's still
around
selling buckets of food for the end
times and now the end times have caught
up
but um jim baker uh
and the royal child tier of is the
higher tier the 20 podcast uh
patreon tier and i know some people like
that seems anti-semitic not some people
one person
comic and i'm like i know you can't make
jokes but at least
try to understand them when they happen
uh the two
uh tears are skull and bones and
rothschilds because it's the two
conspiracy you know the introductory
conspiracies columbones when you get
initiated at yale
and then obviously most people believe
that the biggest you know
it all leads to the rothschilds whether
obviously it's not true
but it's funny uh to put them as the two
tiers on the patreon you know so
lighten hey lighten up out there
truly you know um
and good luck to the kids
going back to school don't listen to
anything your teacher says
move to calabasas start making youtubes
and get a gun
because your teachers have no idea about
the world they've never left
their [__] classroom they have no
idea they're they're they go go home and
drink wine
okay and all they do is plan vacations
if you spoke to a teacher
if you speak to a teacher outside of
school they only talk about the
vacations they're going
on because they have 17 vacations a year
okay so if you're a kid out there and
you listen to this program
um just understand that
jake paul is a much better role model
than your teacher
okay he knows more about what you need
to do to succeed than your teacher
[__] living like scarface big
mansion
he's got guns everywhere he's got guns
leaning on the hot tub
he's got an rpg sticking out of the
sauna
that's how you want you want to live
like that or you want to be some wage
slave sucker
just start dancing start talking
start getting on the god damn internet
this is what i would say to the kids if
they brought me in
and show them a picture of j paul's
house with the guns and say you want to
live like that
or you want to live like your father
your father can't pay his [__] bills
couldn't even afford a gun this guy's
got
10. who do you want to live like all the
kids kind of looking at me
you want to live like him that guy's a
boxer
and he's got a he's got an arsenal and
he raps
he released a rap song it's actually not
horrible
that's the thing now everything is at a
point now where it act
nothing's actually that bad because
everything's bad so actually
nothing's that bad everything i want to
[__] on
i listen to and i go oh this is bad but
it's just like regular bad
like everything that has
been in recent memory
everything is kind of bad the only thing
that is not bad right now do you know
what it is
uh old man river the song no
the only thing that's not bad right now
is the condition i left my apartment
that was not bad and i said keep the
security
that's the only thing right now that's
not bad
email us fun roommate stories do we have
an email on this program yeah the tim
dillon show gmail.com
email us we're not going to read them
send them on over
set them on over get it off your chest
we're not going to read it and i won't
mention them on the show
but send them over get it off your chest
what is it again the tim dillon show at
gmail timberland show gmail.com
put it all in the spam folder but who
cares maybe they're funny maybe we'll
read them should we read them
bad roommates they're horrifying are
they all about me
or people that have lived with me listen
you fat
[__] there's some people that hate me
that i've lived with
yeah don't like me but then there's some
people that liked me
i'm trying to think of all the roommates
that i've had some of them have liked me
some of them
one other woman did not like me i lived
with one woman in brooklyn who would
take
three bites she she was afraid of
garbage she was afraid to have a garbage
in the apartment because she goes we get
rats
because we have rats i said okay
i don't see any of them because they're
here i'm like oh good it's like the
nutcracker they come out at night with
swords
so she uh she would take three bites out
of the northeast corner of her toast and
put it in the refrigerator every morning
she had a bag of garbage
hanging on the kitchen door that she
would throw stuff out in
uh and then she would walk it out every
night like she wouldn't have a car there
was no garbage right
so you're living with someone who has a
problem you know what i mean
she has a little bit of a problem and uh
she did
not like me um
we did not get along i wanted a garbage
yeah it was
kind of a point of contention between
both of us and she
was trying to explain to me that we
couldn't have a garbage
and i wanted a garbage the first my
first roommate i ever had
was a woman who and her and her husband
were
she was a meth had she was recovering
nice woman
not really but me and her lovely now and
she had a husband and they
they got married in a gymnasium in
brooklyn
and uh you know they were comedians and
i lived there we had we had a shower in
the kitchen
the bathroom was in the hall of the
building and another apartment could use
it we had a public bed we used a public
bathroom
the building was built in 1911 we had
bed bugs multiple times it was not
a healthy environment for anybody and
they didn't love me and i didn't love
them
he was just he was just too close for
comfort they had just gotten
married that didn't last but it was a
good money grab they got some money at
the time is good money grabbed him you
know
um then the next roommate i had was a
woman uh with the toast
and the no garbage and she was a strange
skittish
cat-like woman very pensive not someone
uh
not an enjoyable person riddled with
anxiety
before anxiety became a fad i mean real
anxiety a strange woman
pale woman ghost-like young but old
if you know what i mean she would smoke
cigarettes and stare at the the night
sky
outside the building we lived on uh
the other side of prospect park in
brooklyn a strange woman and
i didn't have a door to my room i had a
curtain
just had a curtain and uh one day she
called me and she's like uh i need you
out it's not working out nothing could
really happen
but i was like okay and i
i went you know what sucks as i went i
was like behind and i wasn't behind on
rent but i was behind
like in my world because i i give a rent
on the first but it was like
almost the first i didn't have all the
money so i went and i did a lot of tours
on my tour bus
i was really good and i got all this
money and i finally had it it was one of
those new york moments i'm like
i did it i was down to the wire i gave
three tours i earned like 300
on each tour in tips i walked out with
like 350 i had enough to go get a slice
of pizza and just sit there be like i
[__] did it
i have the rent and then she called me
before i even gave it to her she's like
yeah i just think it's not working out
it's because i don't know if i want a
roommate or whatever you know and i'm
like
great then i call my [__] aunt my
aunt kathleen
the pretend lawyer in my family she's
actually a lawyer but she can't
uh practice because she can't exist in
an environment with other people so she
has a pretend office
downstairs in the basement she goes into
and the phone's not even hooked up and
she goes
i'm an attorney it's like for dick it's
literally the uh case she's
she's unwell and she uh
i called her for some legal support
she's like you've got nothing
all she has to give you is 30 day notice
she's like you got to get out of there
i'm like
she's now yelling at me to get out i'm
like wait what what's happening
what happened to family so then then
i moved in with a palestinian kid named
mazin he was a bartender
not a bad looking kid kind of a
good-looking palestinian
kid you know and uh
you know and then he he one day called
me and he goes
this was three days and again when you
don't have credit you don't have money
and you're living in the underground
economy you're rooming with people that
are
also in that position or or they're
if you have credit and money you're not
living in the places i lived so the idea
that some of those people had the credit
to get a lease the money
uh but they're still somehow like in
this swamp
this horrible building i mean we lived
next to a pest control place in astoria
and there was like a picture of a bed
bug a huge one
right outside my apartment so i just
like looked at a photo of a bed bug
and you'd go home every day and you'd
look at just pictures of roaches and bed
bugs
that were all over this building and
then we live right right next door
imazin i think that was his name i'm
almost positive and he called me one day
he goes
hey bro i'm not stupid you try to [__]
me over and i don't i don't play that
[__]
so you better [__] come clean right
now and admit what you did and i go
well i don't i'm at a loss and he goes
the the uh the utilities with 37 each
man
i'm like yup and he goes i just [__]
counted
and he goes and i'm not stupid i i got
from you
and i'm like well maybe one fell or
i could have miscounted it was early in
the morning before i left for work
he's like just don't [__] around with
the money man
what he said he goes don't [__] around
with the money
so then uh i said okay and then after a
few months in there i said i just got to
go i just
again left him the security just said i
just got to go i got to get out of there
um and then the next roommate i had was
my grandmother on long island who would
say i was a louse and a carnival blocker
and would tell me to go [__] in my hat
she'd say go [__] in your hat and she
would drink scotch and
she would say why don't you get one
thing from mcdonald's for breakfast get
one thing and i said why would i get one
thing and she looked at me and she goes
because you're one person
she was a hilarious woman and then the
next roommate
had i had oh my grandmother oh yeah and
the next roommate i had was
oscar yeah wait wait no
no it was alan an astoria for a few
years he was a nice guy who i like
and then after alan the next roommate in
los angeles was
oscar the cat from instagram who's a
terrorist
would scream blood curling screams in
the middle of the night
and you'd let him in and then he would
like
eat food and then [__] on the floor and
then you'd have to let him back out
i mean he was a terrorist you know and i
would always catch him maybe on the dark
web trying to order weapons
he'd be in radical chat rooms trying to
get people ready
you know for something for a
quote-unquote big event he always said
i mean this is a cat that was literally
a real problem she's wanted by the fbi
for inciting violence
and threatening sitting members of
congress um
and then the next roommate i had was
this this uh lass and uh
it was short when did i move in there
january 15th
january
january 15th and what day is it today
today is august 7th and it's all over
yeah just like that just like that
happens just like that that's why jake
paul smart his only roommates are guns
it's a smart kid
january 15th i moved in you know the
exact date how do you know the date
uh because i remember the podcast
episode we did skid ray
was around that time wow because we
built the new studio in that room yeah
did ray come right after i moved i don't
feel like he did
you guys were up in like canada and then
you came back
or it was ray's first time visiting l.a
so yeah but that was march but i moved
in
in january yeah and february and then
quarantine happened and that just kind
of here's the thing man i don't wanna i
don't wanna burst anybody's bubble
but any friendship you have a
relationship if it's not real rock solid
this quarantine is gonna [__] shred
it
it's gonna shred it because a lot of
people are feeling pressures right now
that they've never felt
people are handling it in different ways
so if you do not have a real
rock solid understanding of the dynamic
of what's going on
this quarantine is gonna really do it in
it's true the quarantine is gonna do it
in
you know and that's okay
because here's the reality when the
quarantine first happened
and that coronavirus hit you know
everybody was like nothing's ever going
to be the same and i i was like yeah
that's kind of true
that's kind of true every relationship
you're in every setup
uh iran i mean ben is leaving the show
next week and he's being replaced by lee
syat
and that's because of the quarantine and
all the stresses and the pressures that
we're feeling
we're bringing lisa and so
you know in closing here i just want to
really
speak to you from the heart and just
tell you
that this is going to be okay we're
going to get on the other side of this
many of us won't be alive
country will be changed forever but
right now
if things are starting to get strained
with your significant other
if things are starting to feel
like to go in the wrong way in a
business relationship or in a friendship
accept it don't fight it
because this has exposed
all of the fault lines in many of the
things that we do
as a country as individual people do not
fight the changing of the guard here do
not
fight what has to happen you will not
emerge from this period
the same person you were when you
started if you do
you've made a huge mistake there has
never ever
been a better time to re-evaluate
what you were doing why you were doing
it who you were surrounding yourself
with
100 and that is
maybe one of the hardest lessons to
learn from this period of time
it's that it should change
things and you should look around there
are couples listening to this right now
uncomfortable
we get hundreds of thousands of
downloads on the show between the
youtube and the audio
there are couples right now listening to
this and they're uncomfortable
out there because they are realizing
that what i'm saying is
true okay and i'm
speaking to those couples okay
i'm speaking to them not as couples but
as individuals
okay when you are in a situation where
you know
things are headed down a bad path
if you're a fan of my show you know
things aren't going to be
the right way things you know one of you
has you know something that didn't work
out
every relationship somebody has
something you know what i mean
every relationship people are in
somebody has there's some problems going
on
somebody's maybe on a diet somebody
doesn't like
somebody writes an article about
somebody in the in the la times
who knows every relationship
has stresses and pressures okay
all of them do and it is it is our job
to recognize these things to not
fight the inertia what is happening what
is coming don't fight him
i mean if you are if you're one of those
couples
right now that you know you feel like
things are going downhill because of
coronavirus don't
drag this out don't let it go on forever
okay steal their money
steal their money
goodbye